all right last night we told you about
the 1.3 trillion dollar omnibus spending
bill under consideration by Congress
this is it look at this look at Singh
this is 1/10 of it right here now we
don't want to we don't want to kill all
the trees so we only printed out 1/10 of
it but we did the math and this is how
big it is
how many people are reading this bill no
one's reading the bill this is what it
is ok
this is a Republican Congress it's a
business-as-usual spender Rama at a time
when voters expected just the opposite
from a president who campaigned against
the corrupt ik rats in DC well well the
sequester cabs gone Republicans what are
they doing today they're linking arms
with Democrats yes they're spending more
on things we should not be funding at
all and things the president vowed to
defund so how on earth do Republicans
expect the voters to turnout in November
for them if they can't live up to the
basic precepts of what they campaigned
on this ridiculous omnibus so we have to
keep moving the camera angles here but
this thing people have to see what this
is because you don't really get it if
you don't see it look at this thing
again I want you to see this this is
your tax dollars at work this is it 1.6
billion dollars in this disaster is
devoted to border security that's it and
a paltry 641 million to the wall the
president campaigned on how many times
that's a pittance and it's not even
close to what the president requested to
ensure that the wall would actually get
built not just lip service well last
night I raised this concern and others
too Majority Whip Steve Scalise this is
an opportunity congressman to defund
sanctuary cities and to get the real
money for the wall that the president
campaigned on and he won the election on
that wall defund Planned Parenthood half
a billion dollars I know you agree with
me on this but a half a billion dollars
to Planned Parenthood the Republicans
are in charge and they punt it I that
he's mine while in a second all right
well we didn't hear what he said there
but he was trying so it's like he agrees
with us but well
perhaps the president was actually
watching the angle I hope so
earlier today he reconsidered his
support of the omnibus bill and he
called Speaker Paul Ryan and Majority
Leader McConnell to the White House for
a meeting now in a statement White House
press secretary Sarah Sanders announced
the president and the leaders discuss
their support for the bill which
includes more funds to rebuild the
military such as the largest pay raise
for our troops in a decade more than a
hundred miles of new construction for
the border wall and other key domestic
priorities like combating the opioid
crisis and rebuilding our nation's
infrastructure hmm now this is curious
Ryan and McConnell obviously pushed the
president to support this bill any right
there are some good things in the bill
but the big push was mr. president you
cannot afford a government shutdown on
Friday now that's how they always do it
they make you agree to blow your
promises and your principles by putting
a gun to your head also be terrible and
shut the government down
look it pains me to say this but the
president is buying a pig in a poke here
he won calling out the establishment on
naming names yes even it would have made
things uncomfortable I have a question
where did that Donald Trump go and where
does all our money go in this bill
that's too big for even us to show on
camera regularly
well it's money by the way that we don't
have worry they're gonna have to borrow
from China Japan or Germany etc or print
but where does it go in this
discretionary part of this spending
Leviathan
well the Pentagon budget balloons to an
obscene seven hundred billion dollars
that's more than 80 billion dollars over
current limits yes I said eighty billion
dollars sanctuary cities fully funded
jerry brown's happy planned parenthood a
half a billion dollars to the death
factory Oh in something called get this
Community Development Block Grants to
cities that's by the way what President
Trump wanted strip from this budget will
nearly doubled to five point two billion
dollars and then there's the Obama era
transportation grant program known as
tiger I don't know what that is I love
Tigers
can't love this this would have its
budget triples to 1.5 billion I could go
on and on and on well I got an hour
tonight now if I were advising the
president I want to tell him take this
as an opportunity tonight to challenge
the GOP leadership
there'd be no signature on the omnibus
bill without a guarantee of full funding
for the wall and a total defunding of
the sanctuary cities across this country
and another thing he should never sign
this omnibus spending bill without first
securing a commitment from Democrats to
allow confirmation votes for all of his
major nominees which are clearly stuck
in committee and I'm talking about
ambassadors like Rick Grinnell for
ambassador to Germany and so many others
judges district court judges and
assistant secretaries deputy secretaries
other key personnel this is the bare
minimum that the president should agree
to this move would also have the added
benefit not the primary but an added
benefit of taking the focus off stormy
Daniels and company and all the other
people are putting on TV on the other
cables and return the focus to substance
that's where Trump does best the
American people did not elect Trump or
the GOP Congress to fill the swamp we
elected them to drain it and the fact
that the military contractors and
lobbyists are clinking champagne glasses
at Washington steak houses tonight that
should concern everyone the conservative
approach is to shrink government not
expanding spending more and perpetuating
Obama era programs is a recipe for
fiscal and electoral disaster even with
some of the good stuff that is in this
bill and that's the angle